hey this is preshtal Walker solve the
following equation a cubed minus a
squared is equal to 18.
variations of this problem have been
shared online with the title that it's a
math Olympiad problem and there's a
trick you should know to solve questions
like this
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
the first thing we'll do is we'll
subtract 18 from both sides so we have a
cubed minus a squared minus 18 is equal
to zero
this is the standard form of the
polynomial and we now want to solve for
the roots or zeros of the polynomial
so I've seen many videos about questions
like this and people at this point just
start guessing convenient values like 0
1 and so on until you get lucky
but there is a trick you should know if
you have a polynomial with integer
coefficients you should use the rational
root theorem
so what this States is you want to look
for particular candidates which will be
rational roots of this polynomial
so here's how it works you take a look
at the constant coefficient which is 18
and then you take a look at the
coefficient of the highest power so in
this case we want to take a look at the
coefficient of a cubed in this case the
coefficient is 1.
so the candidates for roots of this
polynomial will be plus or minus factors
of the constant term 18 divided by
factors of the leading coefficient 1.
so what are factors of 18 18 factors
into 1 times 18 2 times 9 and 3 times 6.
so by the rational root theorem we look
for plus or minus factors of 18 which
will be 1 2 3 6 9 and 18 divided by
factors of 1 1 only has one factor which
is one
so this gives us candidate routes that
we can check plus or minus one two three
six nine eighteen we don't need to check
for zero we don't need to check for four
if there's a rational root it'll be one
of these candidates so we'll just start
checking let's try a is equal to one we
substitute in and we see this is not a
zero of the equation
we can try a is equal to two and once
again we get unlucky
but what about a is equal to three
we get lucky three cubed minus three
squared minus eighteen is equal to zero
so we found a root of this equation
now we can simplify matters tremendously
since a is equal to 3 is a root of the
equation
a minus 3 will be a factor of the
polynomial
so we will use polynomial long division
we take a cubed minus a squared minus 18
and we divide it by a minus 3. now when
you do polynomial long division you want
to have all of the placeholders set we
don't have any coefficient for the
linear Factor so let's just insert that
we want 0 times a so now we're all set
so first we want to eliminate the a
cubed term so we need to multiply a by a
squared so we take a squared multiplied
by a minus 3 and this is equal to a
cubed minus 3 a squared we will subtract
this from the original polynomial and we
have to be careful about the opposite of
negative 3A squared will be plus 3A
squared so we end up with 2A squared now
we drop down the zero multiplied by a
now to eliminate 2A squared we need to
multiply by 2A
so we add 2A here then we take 2A
multiplied by a minus 3 this works out
to be 2A squared minus 6A we want to
subtract this entire term
this works out to be 6A we then bring
down negative 18 so to eliminate 6A we
have to add 6 so we have 6 multiplied by
a minus 3 that works out to be 6A minus
18 and finally we subtract this and this
works out to be zero so there's no
remainder
so the original polynomial divided by a
minus 3 is equal to a squared plus two a
plus 6.
so in other words
a minus 3 multiplied by a squared plus
2A plus 6 is equal to the original
polynomial
now we want this to be equal to zero so
that means either a minus 3 is equal to
0 or the quadratic is equal to zero if
the first factor is equal to zero that
means a is equal to three we already
knew that so now we solve this quadratic
equation to be equal to zero
we will use brahmagupta's quadratic
formula and we just substitute in so a
is equal to negative two plus or minus
the square root of 2 squared minus four
multiplied by 1 multiplied by six this
is all over two
so we simplify under the radical this
will be negative 20.
now negative 20 is equal to four
multiplied by negative five so the
square root of 4 is equal to two we pull
that out now we divide through by two so
that a is equal to negative 1 plus or
minus I root 5.
and that's the solution to the original
question
a is equal to 3 or a is equal to
negative 1 plus or minus I root 5. and
that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve The World's
problems one video at a time